our greatest enemy is that we keep
waiting for someone to someone to give
us a shot and if you haven't had enough
shots
you're just failing under their watchful
eye
justin we had this comment come in from
one of our viewers and it reads guys i'm
so scared there's a certain amount of
movies i want to create and i figured
the best route to start would be with
screenwriting but i just wish i had a
guide or something for the journey it
seems like people really spend years
doing so much work and only have results
after like a decade
i'm not sure if i want to be a
screenwriter but i do know that i have
movies i want made
help what advice can you all give me
so wow
uh
pictures that he wants to get made but
not quite sure how to go about it and
doesn't want to spend decades doing
something he doesn't love or she don't
you know doing stuff they don't love
in order to make that happen
i would say pick a discipline
and
know that that's your focus
and just start making stuff
just start making stuff i think
everybody gets so caught up in all the
reasons why they can't do something and
never think about why they can
and i don't know what that is about us
as artists that
that makes that thought pop into your
head but
whenever i do something my wife will
tell you i tell you a thousand and one
reasons why we'll succeed and you'll
have to tell me all the reasons why we
can't and i'll tell you every reason why
i can overcome that too
that's really what it's about get out
there and make it happen
just get out there and make it happen if
you know that screenwriting isn't where
you want to be see if you can get
somebody who is a screenwriter to do
that part of it and then you just get
out there and you make it i don't know
what it is this person was trying to
to
what discipline they were trying to work
in whether it was producing directing
writing acting i don't know but whatever
it is know that that's your main thing
and the pieces that you don't want to
concern yourself with in terms of
learning how to do it and becoming very
proficient
i would say piece piece work that
piecemeal that out like get someone else
who is just as eager to create something
as yourself
and say let's create this together you
handle that part i'll handle these parts
and just do it that way and just get to
creating just start creating stuff
have you always had that belief in
yourself
where you can think of all these reasons
why you will succeed
no no i don't think i've always had that
i think that i've always been
i think i've always been by myself
wanting people to include me in
something
and
i went through my life with that
until one day i no longer cared what
everybody else was thinking or doing or
willing to accept me
and that's what was able to help me
become more and more successful
because i realized
the only
difference between like i'm the only
difference between possible and
impossible that's really it
i am
so
if that is the truth and i don't really
need any of these other people i don't
need their approval i don't need their
guidance i don't i don't need anything i
can go over here and start making my own
mistakes when i speak to someone else i
want to learn from their mistakes that's
what i want to learn from whatever
advice you have it came from your
mistakes i want to know about your
mistakes if you have something to share
if you don't just don't stand in my way
you know because the train is moving
this direction if you stand there i'll
run you over because this is where i'm
going so i don't really need any of it
um i can i can i came to a realization
that
when i made adam k adam k if you look at
it i had to make up credits because i
didn't want to look like i did
everything but i did everything
i did it was me and my wife
she handled uh holding the boom pole she
did makeup she did special effects she
handled catering and
i
handled everything else
you know and it was the two of us making
a movie
and we made it for 1500 bucks and
everybody thinks we spend a crapload
more than that but nope that's all we
spent
and
it was proof i don't need
a bunch of people to make that happen
and neither does anyone else
sit down take a camera or camera phone
or something and start shooting
something
was there a specific incident or
something that happened that made you
realize i don't i don't need
the group um
that you're willing to share no i mean i
think it i think more than anything it
was it was the constant
disappointment
because
when you're starting out and you don't
have very much money you
you start to see who will work with you
for very little money right
so their incentive is only that very
little money that's it it's not the
passion it's not growing with you it's
not any of that stuff they have no
investment in your journey or theirs
whatsoever they want that 50 bucks or
100 bucks that you can pay them and
guess what happens if somebody else
comes along and says they'll give them
200 bucks they will be off your set and
you will be there by yourself and that
happened to me excuse me numerous times
numerous times
where people would just bail i was
shooting something a short film and they
just bail and that's it or they don't
show up and you're like what what is
this you know
and so i went into to adam k and i just
i wanted to see can i shoot this myself
i shot another film called bleed for me
and i shot that one completely by myself
that one was me taking the boom pole and
propping it up in a corner so that it
would capture audio and then i would
shoot with it with the camera and i
would be setting up the lights and i
would order food and bring it over you
know i literally shot bleed for me by
myself and edited it
you know
but it was because so many people that i
brought aboard flaked just flaked and
flaked and flaked and i just i began to
realize i don't need any of these people
actually
i mean it's good to have them around you
know it lightens the load a bit but i
don't need them
and so once i once i really realized
that my only reason for bringing someone
on board if i have the money to pay them
well
you only
your your
the reason why you're on this project is
because you do something better than i
could myself
and you truly do lighten the load but if
it's something that i realize at any
point that i'm just better off doing it
myself i will
i'll just do it myself
because it's better off that way
how does someone maximize their chances
for breaking in
in hollywood whatever breaking in is
um
[Music]
in the shortest answer
the same way
you can increase your odds of winning a
boxing match throw a whole lot of
punches
now does that mean you'll win no it just
gives you
a puncher's chance right so if you just
keep taking your shot taking your shot
taking your shot eventually something
will land hopefully
now
if you're looking at a more skillful way
to get there and to continue to work i
say perfect your craft
and constantly take opportunities to
get more experience and to be helpful
to put yourself in a position to better
utilize
those muscles and those strengths of
yours and and make those weaknesses no
longer a weakness make them an advantage
you know start to do that so that you
become you become not only
better at the craft
but you can navigate the system a little
bit better because that is more helpful
um
but i think those are the ways you you
increase your odds as well
in a more calculated way
and i tell people too i i tell this to
actors i tell this to writers i tell it
to anybody
keep creating your own content
keep creating because even though you no
one is going to come
looking just odds nobody's going to come
looking at your web series and saying
that needs to be on nbc that's not
really happening but
what it does it allows you to grow it
allows you to do what most people would
do in a film school which is you get to
fail
and fail
and fail
and fail until you're no longer failing
right
our greatest enemy is that we keep
waiting for someone as someone to give
us a shot and if you haven't had enough
shots you're just failing under their
watchful eye
that's all you're doing
so why not do that on your own
you know just shoot some stuff
get more experience work through your
strengths understand what your strengths
are and what your weaknesses are and
begin to work through those things and
make those you know your advantages as
well and just become all around
uh a great technician in your craft as
well as a great creative in your in your
craft